certains le disaient avec des fleurs ce
matin d'autres avaient choisi la
matraque
le front national pour quelques injures
de trop le service d'ordre de jean marie
le pen est intervenue sans contrôle
coups de matraque sur des passants
lacrymogènes bris de vitre devant des
gardes-mobiles passif est débordé un
marché champ de bataille
[Applaudissements]
pourtant sur le marché la campagne
continue calme et poli c'est jusqu'au
repli stratégique face à une centaine de
manifestants anti front national une
contre attaque avec légumes et
projectiles divers
les gardes mobiles font barrage barrage
jusqu'au départ de jean-marie le pen
ensuite les militants seront face à face
m
ceux du front national sont cette fois
pris à partie intervention des forces de
l'ordre fouillent des voitures armes
blanches confisquer un véritable arsenal
et puis plusieurs interpellations 4 ici
14 plus loin des militants front
national venu pour régler des comptes
gardanne jours de campagne jean marie le
pen a qualifié cette virée électorale de
petite matinée d'exercices